this is the armed forces tournament up
first the sergeant's duel where a
sergeant from the army will go up
against an active duty staff sergeant
from the air force all right guys you
will be building
the m1915 bolo bayonet
the m1915 bolo bayonet was a hybrid
version of the bolo knife and a
traditional bayonet originally designed
at the turn of the 20th century this
versatile battle weapon featured the
lightweight curved blade of the bolo
ideal for slashing through dense jungles
the muzzle hole guard attaches the blade
to the end of the rifle where it's used
to inflict deadly stabs against rival
troops only six thousand bolo bayonets
were issued before they were
discontinued by world war ii making it
extremely rare and valuable to
collectors my name is furman lopez i am
52 years old i work for the va hospital
and i'm a part-time bladesmith from
north carolina
when i first joined the military i got
into the aviation brigade our unit got
activated we ended up heading over to
iraq and pretty much everything just
flew from there every minute counts in
this competition so while i'm waiting
for this canister to get up in
temperature i say to myself let's get
started on the guard i get a marker and
i started painting my shape when the
canister looks like it's almost white
that's when it's forging temperature
it's moving the way i want it it's nice
and hot it's just moving great now that
the billet is the size that i want i go
over the big blue because the belly has
to be at least two inches
now that i have the belly to the
parameters that i need it's time to get
it ready for the quenching i go in for
the quench
there we go berman's in the oil
i pull it out and i see no bends nothing
at this point i'm looking at my knife
and i'm like let's start putting it
together
all right let's get this body started i
picked the leather stack it's quick it's
easy and it works
my name is joseph collette i'm an e5 in
the united states air force
and uh hope i kick some army ass i am
currently active duty seer specialist
seer is survival evasion resistance
escape i teach them how to survive the
worst days of their life i get my weld
set in the press and then i move over to
big blue my plan is to draw those out
and then cut them into threes and that's
gonna be 39 layers in each billet bring
it over the press and give it a little
bit of loving all right joe's
consolidating those wells and the
over 200 layers of steel i've got my
billet into a blade shape and i'm trying
to get to a quench
so my plan right now is just to do the
edge points
so by edge quenching i ensure that the
edge is hard without causing a warp
[Music]
saying don't crack
don't bend
[Music]
pull it out it's good enough and then
it's on to the grinder to grind this
thing to shape
now it's time to put my handle on i've
already prepped my two pieces of micarta
put a little bit of glue on
and i have a handle that is on i've got
my blade shape and i look in i see this
little bubble and like oh great we got a
blister
like really
so i just do a quick weld try to get as
much of it off as possible
i weld it up got this soft spot that's
now developed on my blade while it's
still hot i just shove that thing in the
water it's better to be hard and soft
coming down the last seconds of the
round i need to try to get as much of a
blister off as possible because i almost
guarantee they're gonna whack that blade
right on that spot
five four three
two
one bites miss this round is over
all right gentlemen it's test time up
first is the strength test
i'll be taking your 1915 bolo bayonets
and stabbing them into these fuel cans
and then striking the fuel cans
furman you're up are you ready yes i'm
ready all right
all right furman um it's a comfortable
handle i like your choice thank you as
far as your blade goes
it's held up very well
it's sharp
got some weight in this thing but that's
fine i mean this is a chopping machine
this was meant to be chopping through a
jungle
all in all nice job thank you sir thank
you
all right joe you ready yeah let's do it
all right joe we realized that you had
that d-lam that blister on the side i
think you made a really good choice to
fill that with weld
and i hit the edge right above that
thing so you didn't lose the temper on
that edge nice
but
you're kind of missing the waist on this
blade
so the profile becomes a much more
elongated cutting edge as opposed to the
belly and then the waist
as far as your handle goes it's a little
on the round and smooth side it has the
ability to turn you could easily lose an
inch of that handle probably would have
made it a much more secure blade in my
hand because it's got a lot of weight to
it
but the blade is in
the same shape it started out in
and you didn't really lose any of the
sharpness so really well done thank you
all right bladesmiths this is the
sharpness test the military bed stab and
slice
now to find out how sharp your weapons
are i'm going to take your bolo bayonets
and stab and slice on this military bed
come in you're up first you ready yes
sir right let's do this
about your bolo bayonet here
first up in profile it looks very much
like the sample that we had out there
now let's talk about your edge your edge
is sharp it was so sharp that actually
because of the weight
whoa it surprised me cutting into this
military bed overall sir you're bowl
obeying it
you'll cut yes
all right joe your turn so you ready oh
yeah let's do this
all right
all right joe let's talk about your bowl
of bayonet here first up your handle
construction
it is a little bit on the longer side i
really need to hold on to this a little
bit more to be able to get that
retention going
your edge
and your tip are quite sharp
stabbing through and cutting on this cot
with no resistance and overall sir your
bolo bayonet it will cut awesome
well guys you both nailed it with your
bowler bayonets they're both strong they
are both extremely sharp but only one of
you guys is going to move forward in
this competition to the final round
the blade smith who's going to be moving
forward into the final round of the
armed forces redeployment tournament is
barman congratulations man
now joe unfortunately you're not gonna
be moving forward in this competition
i'm gonna have to ask you to please step
off the fourth floor
thank you joe this was
truly down to the details and no excuses
having the opportunity to participate
again and compete against my fellow
brothers in arms was extremely
challenging but at the same time very
rewarding that i actually was able to
turn in a piece that could be tested and
performed very well
well furman your hard work paid off your
m1915 bola bayonet is taking you on to
the final round of our armed forces
redeployment tournament you just gotta
check the 2 000 and a seat in the finals
man congratulations thank you thank you
thank you i just cannot believe that i'm
actually moving into the next round
man i almost passed out
you ready to bring your a game for the
finals absolutely good job bud i am so
excited to move on to the next round of
the competition i want to become the
fortune fire champion i'm on my way to
it i want to do it
you